برسمه دولارات وجمال واستقبال رسمي محمد
رمضان يثير الجدل مجددا مهرجان كان يعيد
الاعتبار لجماهيريه جوني ديب عيد ميلاد
الزعيم ونوستالجيا في جده اليكم الابرز
الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
توجهت انظار عشاق السينما وصناعها الاسبوع
الماضي الى فرنسا التي شهدت افتتاح الدوره
السادسه والسبعين لمهرجان كان السينمائي
حيث تصدرت النجمه الفرنسيه كاترين دانوف
بوستر المهرجان وكرم في حبل الافتتاح
النجم الامريكي مايكل دوجس بالسعف الذهبيه
الفخريه وافتتحت فعاليات الدور الحاليه
بفيلم جيندو باغيه من بطوله جوني ديب تحت
اداره المخرج او الممثله الفرنسيه
في الفيلم وتلا عرضه لحظات عاطفيه لنجم
الامريكي متاثرا بتصفيق الحار والمطول في
القاعه
واحتفى حضور المهرجان الاسبوع الماضي
بالعرض الاول لفيلم قتلت زهره القمر من
اخراج مارتنز كورسيزي وبطوله ليوناردو دي
كابريو وروبرت دينيرو وذلك قبل انطلاق
عروضه رسميا في امريكا والعالم
[تصفيق]
مش انا عيد ميلادي النهارده حفاوه كبيره
ايضا وكبت الاحتفاء بعيد ميلاد الزعيم
عادل امام الثالث والثمانين على منصات
التواصل في مصر والعالم العربي الاسبوع
الماضي ونشر الفنان محمد امام عبر صفحته
الرسميه على فيسبوك فيديو يلخص فيه مسيره
والده علق عليه بالقول اعظم وانجح فنان في
التاريخ وحشتنا يا زعيم حاله الاشتياق
والامتنان والاحتفاء بمسيره النجم المصري
برزت ايضا في معايدات العديد من نجوم الفن
في المحروسه عبر حساباتهم الرسميه على
منصات التواصل
كما نشر مدير اعمال عادل امام صوره حديثه
تجمعه به من الاحتفاء بعيد ميلاده هذا
العام وكذلك فنانون الاخرون منهم الفنان
خالد سرحان
وحقق الفنان المصري خالد سرحان تفاعلا
كبيرا على فيسبوك الاسبوع الماضي من خلال
صوره معدله على فوتوشوب يظهر فيها وهو
جالس في ميكروباص وبجانبه القليل من
الجنيهات بدات ردا ساخرا على صوره نشرها
زميله الفنان محمد رمضان وهو يجلس بطائره
خاصه والى جانبه روزا من الدولارات اثارت
الجدل مجددا ورد رمضان على سرحان بالطريقه
ذاتها فاعاد الاخير نشر الصوره وعلق عليها
بالقول ادفع لك كل اشتريت الميكروباص كما
تم تداول اسم النجم المصري المثير للجدل
محمد رمضان كثيرا الاسبوع الماضي بعد نشره
فيديو من لقائه برئيس السلطه الفلسطينيه
محمود عباس
اهلا وسهلا
كيف حالك الحمد لله رب العالمين
وبعد رحلته الفنيه الى امريكا اعلن رمضان
عن مجموعه من المشاريع خلال الصيف المقبل
ومن مصر الى السعوديه ومدينه جده تحديدا
التي شهدت تقديم المسرحيه الغنائيه
للسراضيه نوستالجيا لمغنيه الاوبرا
السوريه باشا رزق وحققت تفاعلا على منصات
التواصل في المملكه بين عشاق اغاني
المسلسلات الكرتونيه خلال فتره
الثمانينيات والتسعينيات
[موسيقى]
كما احيا المغنيان اللبنانيان اليسا وادم
حفلا جماهيريا في جده الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
واخيرا احتفل المغني الشعبي السوري الشهير
عمر سليمان على طريقته الطريفه باليوم
العالمي للشاي خلال حفل جماهيري احياه في
باريس